-Performing her new song,
"Country Music Made Me Do It,"
please welcome Grammy winner
Carly Pearce!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Country music made me do it ♪
♪ And I'll do it till I die ♪
♪ First time
that I tasted whiskey ♪
I took it way too far ♪
♪ First time I let
the wrong boy kiss me ♪
♪ And learned all about
a broken heart ♪
♪ And I ♪
♪ Left everything
I've ever known behind ♪
♪ And my mama cried ♪
♪ Country music made me do it ♪
♪ Got me drunk
and got me through it ♪
♪ A little heartbreak 80 proof ♪
♪ Over three chords
and the truth ♪
♪ Out of a small town
into a ball gown ♪
♪ Picking me up every time
that I fall down ♪
♪ Everything that I've
done wrong or I've done right ♪
♪ Oh, country music
made me do it ♪
♪ And I'll do it till I die ♪
♪ First time
that I thought about cheating ♪
that I blamed my dad ♪
♪ That time
that I changed my last name ♪
that I changed it back ♪
♪ And I ♪
♪ Said who I was
and didn't have to lie ♪
♪ And when they asked me why ♪
♪ Country music made me do it ♪
♪ Got me drunk
and got me through it ♪
♪ A little heartbreak 80 proof ♪
♪ Over three chords
and the truth ♪
♪ Out of a small town
into a ball gown ♪
♪ Picking me up every time
that I fall down ♪
♪ Everything that I've
done wrong or I've done right ♪
♪ Oh, country music
made me do it ♪
♪ And I'll do it till I die ♪
Oh!
♪♪
♪ I wear all my hair
a little too high ♪
♪ And my heartbreak
on my sleeve ♪
♪ I might be
a little bit crazy ♪
♪ But you can't blame me ♪
♪ Country music ♪
♪ Made me do it ♪
♪ Is guilty for
the things I've done ♪
♪ Country music made me do it ♪
♪ Got me drunk
and got me through it ♪
♪ A little heartbreak 80 proof ♪
♪ Over three chords
and the truth ♪
♪ Out of a small town
into a ball gown ♪
♪ Picking me up every time
that I fall down ♪
♪ Everything that I've
done wrong or I've done right ♪
♪ Oh, country music
made me do it ♪
♪ And I'll do it till I die ♪
♪♪
♪ Mm, mm-mm, mm ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]